in the last video we took a look at this
function f of x y equals x to the fourth
minus 4x squared plus y squared which
has the graph that you're looking at on
the left and we looked for all of the
points where the gradient is equal to
zero which basically means both partial
derivatives are equal to 0. and we
solved that and we found that there were
three different points
the origin 0 0 and then square root of 2
0 and negative square root of 2 0 which
corresponds to this origin here which is
a saddle point and then these two local
minima and it seemed like we had a
reasonable explanation for why this is a
saddle point why both of those are local
minima because we took the second
partial derivative with respect to x i
was kind of all over the board here um
second partial derivative with respect
to x and found that when you evaluate it
at x equals zero you get a negative
number kind of indicating a negative
concavity so it should look like a
maximum
and then when you do the same with the
second partial derivative of y
man i always do this i always leave
leave out the squared on that lower term
there okay so second partial derivative
with respect to y um
you get 2 as a constant a positive and
that kind of indicates that it looks
like a minimum to y so that's why you
know this this origin point looks like a
saddle point because the x direction and
y direction disagree and when you do
this with the other points they kind of
both agree that it should look like a
minimum but i said that's not enough i
said that you need to take into account
the mixed partial derivative term and to
see why that's true
let me go ahead and pull up another
example for you here so
the graph of the function that you're
looking at right now it clearly has a
saddle point at the origin that we can
see visually but when we get the
equation for this function
the equation is f of x y
is equal to
x squared
plus y squared
minus
times x y
now let's go ahead and analyze the
partial differential information of this
function we'll just take its partial
derivatives so the partial with respect
to x
is equal to so we've got
when we differentiate this term we get
2x to x y looks like a constant we do
nothing and then this last term looks
like negative 4 times y because y looks
like a constant so negative
y
and when we do the partial derivative
with respect to y
very similarly we're going to get 2y
when we differentiate y squared to y and
now we subtract minus 4x because x looks
like the constant and y looks like the
variable minus 4
x
now when we plug in x and y are each
equal to 0 you know we plug in the
origin point to both of these functions
we see that they're equal to zero
because x is zero y is zero this guy
goes to zero similarly over here that
goes to zero so we will indeed get a
flat tangent plane at the origin
but now let's take a look at the second
partial derivatives
if we do the second partial derivatives
purely in terms of x and y so if we take
the pure
second partial derivative of f
with respect to x squared
what we get we look at this expression
we differentiate it with respect to x
and we get a constant positive 2
because that y does nothing for us and
then similarly when we take the second
partial derivative
with respect to y always forget that
squared on the bottom
we also get a constant positive 2
because this x does nothing for us when
we take the derivative with respect to y
so we get a constant positive 2. so this
would suggest that you know there's
positive concavity in the x direction
there's positive concavity in the y
direction so it would suggest that you
know it looks like an upward smiley face
from all directions and it should be a
local minimum but when we look at the
graph this isn't true it's not a local
minimum it's a saddle point
so what this tells us is that these two
second partial derivatives aren't enough
we need more information and what it
kind of comes down to is that this last
term here minus 4xy oh actually i think
i made a mistake i think i meant to make
this um
plus 4xy so let's see
plus 4xy which would influence these it
actually won't make a difference it
still gives a saddle point
but anyway we've got this plus 4xy term
that evidently makes a difference that
evidently kind of influences whether
this is a local minimum or maximum and
just to give a loose intuition for
what's going on here if instead of
writing 4 here
i wrote i'm going to write the variable
p okay and p is just going to be some
number and i'm going to move that
variable around i'm going to basically
let it range from 0
up to 4. so right now as you're looking
at it it's sitting at 4. so i'm going to
pull it back and kind of let it range
back to zero just to see how this
influences the graph
and we see that once we pull it back to
zero we get something where it kind of
reflects what you would expect where
from the x direction it's a positive
smiley face from the y direction it's
also a positive smiley face and
everything's good it looks like a local
minimum and it is and even as you let p
range more and more and here p is around
i'm guessing right now it's around 1.5
you get something that's still a local
minimum it's a positive concavity in all
directions but there's a critical point
here where as you're moving p at some
point it kind of passes over and turns
it into a saddle point and again this is
entirely the coefficient in front of the
x y term it has nothing to do with the x
squared or the y squared
so at some point it kind of passes over
and from that point on everything is
going to be a saddle point and in a
moment it'll become clear that that
critical point happens when p is equal
to 2. so right here it's going to be
when p equals two it kind of passes from
making things a local minimum to a
saddle point
and let me show you the the test which
will tell us why this is true so the uh
the full reasoning behind this test is
something that i'll get to in later
videos but right now i just want to kind
of have it on the table and teach you
what it is and how to use it so this is
called the second partial derivative
test
second
partial
derivative test i'll just write
derive test since i'm a slow writer
and basically what it says is if you
found a point where the gradient of your
function at this point and i'll write it
kind of x naught y naught is our point
if you found where it equals zero then
calculate the following value you'll
take the second partial derivative with
respect to x twice so here i'm just
using that subscript notation which is
completely the same as saying you know
second partial derivative with respect
to x twice just different choice in
notation and you evaluate it at this
point
x naught y naught then you multiply that
by the second partial derivative with
respect to y
evaluated at that same point
y naught
and then you subtract off the mixed
partial derivative the one where first
you do it with respect to x then with
respect to y or in the other order it
doesn't really matter as long as you
take it with respect to both variables
you subtract off that guy squared so
what you do is you you compute this
entire value and it's going to give you
some kind of number and let's give it a
name let's name it h
and if it's the case that h is greater
than zero
then you have either a max or a min
you're not sure which one yet
and some max or min and you can tell
whether it's a maximum or a minimum
basically by looking at one of these
partial derivative with respect to x
twice or or with respect to y twice and
kind of getting a feel for the concavity
there right if this was positive it
would indicate kind of a smiley face
concavity and it would be a local
minimum and the fact that this entire
value h is greater than zero is what you
need to tell you that you can just do
that you can look at the concavity with
respect to one of those guys and that'll
tell you the information you need about
the entire graph but if h is less than
zero if h is less than zero
then you definitely have a saddle point
saddle point
and if h is purely equal to zero if you
get that unlucky case then you don't
know then the second partial derivative
test isn't enough to determine but
almost all cases you'll find that either
is purely greater than zero or purely
less than zero
so as an example let's see what that
looks like in the case of the specific
function we started with where p is some
constant that i was letting kind of
range from 0 to 4 when i was animating
it here but you should just think of p
as being some number
well in that case this value h
that we plug in and let's say we're
plugging it at the origin right we're
analyzing at the origin well we've
already calculated the partial
derivative with respect to x twice in a
row and y twice in a row and both of
those when we computed those were just
constants two they were equal to two
everywhere and in particular they're
equal to 2 at the origin so we can go
ahead and just plug in those and we see
that this is 2
times 2 and then now we need to subtract
off
the mixed partial derivative squared
so if we go ahead and compute that where
we take the derivative with respect to x
and then y or y and then x let's say we
started with the partial derivative with
respect to x um when we take this
derivative with respect to y we're going
to get this constant term that's sitting
in front of the y but really it's
whatever this constant p happened to
equal and and you might be able to see
that just looking at this function that
when you take the mixed partial
derivative it's going to be the
coefficient in front of the x y term
because it's kind of like first you do
the derivative with respect to x and the
x goes away and then with respect to y
and that y goes away and you're just
left with a constant
so what you end up getting here in the
second partial derivative test when we
take that value
which is p which might equal 4 or 0 or
whatever we happen to have it as and we
square that we square that
that's going to be the value that we
analyze so in the case where p was equal
to zero right if we go over here and we
scale so that p is completely equal to
zero then our entire value h
h would equal 4.
and because h is positive it's
definitely a maximum or a minimum and
then by analyzing one of those second
partial derivatives with respect to x or
y and seeing that it's positive
concavity we would see oh it's it's a
definitely a local minimum because
positive concavity gives local minimum
but in the other case where let's say we
we let p range such that p is all the
way equal to four
in formulas what that means for us when
we let p
equal four is we're taking 2 times 2
minus 4 squared so we're taking 2 times
2 minus 16.
what that would imply sorry about
getting kind of scrunched on the board
here is that h is equal to let's see 4
minus 16
negative 12. so i'm just going to erase
this to kind of
clear up some room so when p equals 4
this is negative 12.
and in fact this kind of explains the
crossover point for when it goes from
being local minimum to a saddle point
it's going to be at that point where
this entire expression is equal to zero
and you can see that happens when p
equals two so over here the crossover
point when it kind of goes from being a
local minimum to a saddle point is that
p equals two and when p perfectly equals
two let's see so about here um
the second partial derivative test isn't
gonna be enough to tell us anything it's
it can't tell us it's definitely a max
and it can't tell us that it's
definitely a saddle point and in this
particular case that that corresponds to
the fact that the the graph is perfectly
flat in one direction and a minimum in
another direction in other cases it
might mean something different and i'll
probably make a video just about that
special case when this whole value is
equal to zero but for now all that i
want to emphasize is what this test is
where you take all three second partial
derivatives and you kind of multiply
together the two pure second partial
derivatives where you do x and then x
and the one way you do y and y you
multiply those together and then you
subtract off that mixed partial
derivative squared
and in the next video i'll try to give a
little bit more intuition for you know
where this whole formula comes from why
it's not completely random why taking
this and analyzing whether it's greater
than 0 or less than zero
is a reasonable thing to do for
analyzing whether a point that you're
looking at is a local minimum or a local
maximum or a saddle point
see you then